you
we've got stone tools in Britain far
earlier than we thought and in an
environment where we didn't think early
humans were able to live 900 thousand
years ago so it really increases our
understanding of their capabilities at
this time
at the moment sitting of course by the
coast but 800,000 years ago the
landscape would have looked very
different
we'd have been sitting in an early
course of the River Thames in its s3 and
the actual coast would have been about
15 miles out that way the river valley
itself would have been nice and grassy
and open but would have been surrounded
by pine forest and if we carried on
walking down the river to the coast and
carried on walking around the edge of
the coast at this time we were joined to
Europe and we'd end up somewhere like
Amsterdam
the earliest humans evolved in Africa
and they only reached Europe we think
now about 1.6 1.7 million years ago but
they're really limited to the southern
fringes of Europe at this time and until
recently we thought humans didn't reach
Northern Europe - about seven hundred
thousand years ago so we have people at
seven hundred thousand years at Pike
field in Suffolk and those people were
living under Mediterranean conditions
hot dry summers warm wet winters we
thought they were able to come up
briefly in those very warm times and
that's the only time they could get up
here across a land bridge that existed
but now with the new Hayes borough data
we have evidence that even earlier than
that they were actually here under
cooler conditions conditions which were
in some ways comparable with conditions
we might find in say southern
scandinavia at the present day quite
demanding conditions for early humans
and yet they were here in britain
surviving under those conditions the
remarkable thing about Haseman the
reason that we can find this rich
evidence is that as the cliffs erode
back they reveal these river sediments
and these sediments contain remarkable
things like wood animal bones tiny
little things as small as beetle remains
and most importantly of all we have the
evidence of humans in the stone tools
that they left behind
this is one example of the type of flint
tools that were discovering at the site
and in fact we've only found 60 of these
over the last five years work so they're
remarkably rare the important thing is
that they indicate that humans were here
and this particular piece we nicknamed
the butter knife because it's so finely
made and you've got this beautiful
retouch down that edge and in fact this
one piece we sent to the Natural History
Museum
Ct is basically a method for digitally
sectioning an object we take the stone
tool and then using x-rays collect a
series of cross-sectional slices through
the specimen and then stack those slices
up to make a reconstruction of the
specimen but digitally and on a computer
as far as we know this is the first time
anybody's used computed tomography to
analyze stone tools and produce 3d
models and hopefully we can be the first
people to start sharing the data and
really help try and convince people that
what they're looking at is a human may
tool and not just a natural artifact
what Rich's got with this technology is
a way of capturing the shape of these
pieces this flake has been struck off
and we can see here the so-called bulb
of percussion so there was a blow that
detached this flake that was made
purposefully in that position and then
there's been further modification along
the edges by further refined workmanship
so nature might make one or two blows
like this in a river gravel but the
systematic flaking we see on a piece
like that is only done by humans we can
see that it sits very nicely in the hand
and it's got a cutting edge on both
sides one edge a sharper ones more a
blunted scraping surface but this would
have been useful for skinning and
butchering animals getting the meat off
the bones
so we've seen the stone tools that Chris
and Richie were looking at and we
understand how the tools were made and
possibly even used but here on site
we're looking at the context these
gravels were laid down by the ancestral
Thames and Knight has just uncovered a
fragment of woods which is the trunk and
the roots of a small tree and it's
important because we can identify the
plants and the animals that were in the
landscape associated in humans so it
provides a huge amount of information
about the climate's environment in the
landscape at that time so this is just a
range of some of the vertebrate fossils
from the sites this is a tooth of
primitive mammoths these animals showed
that the environment was very rich so
you have a large herbivore fauna but
also the carnivores that were eating
these animals and presumably humans were
also eating some of the large mammals
we've also got aquatic animals this one
here is stunning beautifully preserved
jaw of an extinct semi-aquatic rodent
and you can see the teeth are still in
place in the jaw so again that's another
animal that indicates quite open
environments slow flowing rivers or
ponds large lakes we've also got plant
fossils and because the sediments are
waterlogged and deposited very quickly
the preservation is is truly remarkable
this is a pinecone and it is close to a
million years old but it's it's still
recognizable as a pinecone and from all
of these finds we can build up a very
detailed picture of the environments
from the plant fossils the pollen we
know the vegetation was mostly
coniferous so if you're looking at a
modern-day analogue you would go to the
boreal Zone in in southern Scandinavia
with a mixture of deciduous but dominant
coniferous trees so they're living near
boreal forests and they're surviving
winters that are colder than the present
day and the summers were warm and
reasonable but the winters were cold and
to get through those cold winters they
must have had significant behavioral
adaptations to
with those conditions so it takes us up
a notch in our understanding and
appreciation of what these early people
were capable of and of course there's a
paleontologist I'm hoping we're going to
find some human fossils to go with these
stone tools to really show what these
early people look like
you